que je t'aime que je t'aime que je
t'aime que je t'aime Gabriel ou encore
je te promets ces chansons mythiques
résonnent toujours dans le coeur des
nombreux fans de Johnny Hallyday 5 ans
après sa mort son fan club officiel et
la ville de Voisins-le-Bretonneux se
sont associés pour proposer aux
passionnés une exposition inédite 50
clichés capturés par le photographe
Patrick dewin sont présentés au public à
la maison de Coville depuis 20 ans il
avait cette envie ce désir ce rêve on va
dire de d'accompagner Johnny en tournée
devant le travail qu'il a fait pendant
toutes ces années un jour il lui a dit
pour la tournée 2012 j'accepte que tu
m'accompagnes dans cette tournée
différents clichés que j'ai fait à Los
Angeles
au Stade de France
Carcassonne Brétignolles-sur-Mer je suis
surtout un passionné de Johnny il m'a
toujours intrigué en 1975 j'ai commencé
donc c'est et j'ai suivi Johnny toute ma
vie quoi une bonne photo de Johnny c'est
le vrai cliché quand vous êtes plus près
et vous voyez Johnny qui est en sueur et
qui arrive à pouvoir sa chanson à la
chanter avec cœur ah le magnifique
franchement il y a une belle exposition
de très beaux cadres qui rappellent
beaucoup de souvenirs aussi parce que je
crois que j'ai quand même fait plus ou
moins 200 concert de Johnny un petit peu
partout un clin d'oeil à la ville que
l'icône française du rock avait déjà
visité venu il est venu à voisin il a
tourné le film Jean-Philippe avec
Fabrice Luchini un voisin il y a presque
20 ans donc c'est un petit retour un
petit retour aux sourd Harley voiture de
collection ou encore danseurs de country
était présent pour l'inauguration de
l'exposition objectif rendre hommage à
Johnny et surtout faire perdurer son
souvenir mais c'est même pour nous une
obligation un petit peu un devoir parce
que on a créé ce club il y avait attend
avec Johnny lui-même et moi je tiens
vraiment maintenant qu'il est parti
depuis 5 ans à perpétuer cette légende à
honorer cette mémoire ça reste et ça
restera l'artiste français numéro 1 dans
le cœur des Français c'est évident tous
les clichés présent és sont proposés à
la vente l'exposition se termine le 2
avril prochain